بعد 12 عاما من الغياب سوريا تعود الى
الحضن العربي وتشارك في القمه العربيه
الوفد السوري يضم وزير الخارجيه
والمغتربين فيصل المقداد ومعاونه ايمن
سوسان ومدير مكتبه جمال نجيب
وزير الاعلام بطرس الحلاق مندوب سوريا
الدائمه في الامم المتحده بسام الصباغ
مدير اداره الشؤون العربيه بوزاره
الخارجيه رياض عباس مدير اداره المنظمات
الدوليه والمؤتمرات قصي الضحك
مندوب سوريا الدائمه لدى الجامعه العربيه
في القاهره باسل سكوتي نعبر عن ارتياحنا
لكل التحضيرات التي قامت بها قياده
المملكه وعلى مختلف المستويات ونحن
هنا لانجاح هذه القمه نحن نتطلع الى
الحاضر والى المستقبل
وفدون اقتصادي سوري شارك ايضا في اجتماعات
المجلس الاقتصادي والاجتماعي التحضيريه
للقمه على راسهم وزير الاقتصاد السوري
محمد خليل
[موسيقى]
ندعو الدول العربيه الى المشاركه في
الاستثمار في سوريا في ظل وجود فرص واعده
وقوانين جديده جاذبه للاستثمار
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات